hello everyone and welcome to another
really awesome game from round six of
the fide candidates tournament 2022 it's
already affirmative versus fabiano
corona fabi doing well as usual in the
candidates tournament nothing can
surprise fabi he's he either wins the
candidates or you know he's almost
winning the candidates and it's uh
alireza who this is his first time in
the candidates and so far he's uh played
a really really incredible chess he only
got four draws and one loss but in most
of the games it really could have
gone uh either way uh and his one loss
was the was the yan nipponishi which is
uh well uh
uh you guys have seen the video so you
know all about what happened there uh
but against fabi uh for example uh in
his game against car while ereza started
with the d4 in his game against duda he
started with e4 and now against fabi he
again switches it up and uh plays pawn
to d4 and now this is uh this is the
position uh you guys said that you
wanted uh some more photos so here is
one photo uh it's uh from the opening
basically the first couple of moves have
been played again nothing new unusual
about the photo the the uh the playing
uh conditions and you know the players
are so neat everything is so sterile
there just isn't so much going on as
there was uh you know uh
back in the day like a few years ago uh
so not all that much to discuss but uh
as usual if you guys spot anything out
of the ordinary in the photo i am all
ears i don't know one thing i can maybe
uh point out is that alireza really
looks twice as as as large as fabi like
maybe it's the just the photo of the
camera or rather the angle of the camera
but i don't know there's something off
here it's like he was artificially
enlarged maybe in photoshop or something
but i don't know just thought that that
was funny uh but yeah if you guys bought
anything else you know reading your
comments is one of my favorite things to
do
when it's you know regarding uh the the
photos so you know have at it uh but
yeah i'm getting back to the game now
alireza opens with the d4 we have knight
to f6 c4 and e6 fabi says i'm ready for
anything if you want we can go for a
nice name so indian we can uh you know
i've brought uh everything here for this
tournament but alireza says nope uh not
doing anything crazy i have to uh you
know slow down a little bit let's go for
a nice catalan opening and okay pawn to
d5 we have bishop to g2 bishop to e7 and
knight to f3 we have castles and here uh
there are uh so many moves that were
played it's a very very popular position
the the top moves in this position are
just castles and queen to c2 and uh
pretty much everyone plays this you know
with with a couple of exceptions uh but
the move alireza prepared for fabi has
only been played a handful of times and
that is queen to d3 now the scary thing
and maybe a scary thing for favi is that
it was played by the legend himself the
the the man you all uh love love to
watch you know not just the play but
just you know his presence is so great
is boris gill fund he is the man behind
queen to d3 he had some very good
results with it and the last time he
played it was a couple of months ago in
february in the
uh
in the uh czech republic extra liga he
won a very nice game with it and no
doubt uh alireza has seen this game but
fabi also you know
follows what's happening in the chess
world there's a chance fabi saw this as
well so let's see how fabi deals with it
usually in structures like these you you
want to play a6 b6 and c5 you know in no
particular or order if your opponent
isn't threatening anything so here c5 by
fabi uh we have castles c captures on d4
knight captures and knight to c6
offering a trade of knights c captures
on d5 knight captures on d4 grabbing
that knight queen captures and knight
captures on d5 and here rook to d1 uh
with bishop to f6 attacking the queen
here and now uh what are you going to
play here uh well you have to move the
queen obviously but where are you going
to move the queen now in the game that
i've mentioned uh boris girlfriend had
this exact same position in february
this year against lucas tziborowski uh
and in that game queen to d3 was played
a girlfriend won a very nice victory but
the actual top recommendation by the
engine is a queen to g4 uh okay a queen
to c5 queen to d3 a close second uh but
obviously alireza prepared for this so
just going um
going with queen to g4 and it's a very
odd looking move because you constantly
have to worry about this e5 opening up
an attack towards uh your queen so it's
really really strange
obviously improved on a boris girlfriend
game and that thought is scary in itself
i mean if you know this and you know
okay boys girlfriend played this so it
is just improved on it that's uh you
know uh
you have to be uh incredibly uh brave to
to
to play against something like this uh
but okay this is fabi we're talking
about he just continues development
bishop to d7
and now knight to d2 we have queen to e7
and now knight to f3 now knight to e4
looks really awesome but after bishop e5
there just isn't all that much for you
to do if you go back knight to c3 we can
just go back bishop to f6
or even if you play something weird like
knight to c5 just offering a knight this
can be played but it's nothing really if
queen captures uh we're going to play
bishop captures on d5 because now if you
capture the bishop here hangs so it's
nothing really but you know it's fun so
that's why i'm showing it but knight to
f3 was played in the game now rook a to
c8 and now pawn to e4 attacking the
knight and now you can't just move the
knight if you just move the knight e5
wins the game for all it is that's it
the bishop is trapped um
fabi can resign so e5 now grabbing this
very important tempo on the queen queen
to h5 by alireza and now knight to b4
and what do you play here alareza plays
bishop to g5 again excellent stuff
because if fabi plays something weird uh
let's say play something like rook to c2
and it's a beautiful move who wouldn't
put the rook on the second or you know
on the seventh rank uh it's just is just
like a dream come true the problem is
here uh for example a3 you have to move
the knight and then we pick up the the
bishop here and now the light squares
are incredibly weak and uh black will
not be able to defend this queen
captures on d7 we're going to open up
the king side captures captures and now
bishop h3 and that's it we attack the
queen once the queen moves wherever it
doesn't really matter bishop to f5 and
there is no defending this position uh
rook d8 making some room for the king
but queen h6 we are not allowing this
king to escape bishop captures on h7 is
next and that's a game over so uh fabi
has to capture on g5 uh so bishop
captures and g5 knight captures now
there is a threatens checkmate on h7 and
h6 just kicking away the knight knight
back to f3 and now knight to c6 fabi
could leave the knight here it seems
like more active square could play
something like rook to c5 to defend his
e5 pawn this way because alireza is
attacking it
but he says nope that's a weird looking
position let's go back knight to c6 uh
and now how can all it is a continue
well there are many moves you can play
you can play a3 you can play b4 you can
maybe bring another rook into the game
you could start with knight to h4 try
and bring this knight over to f5 and
then maybe force black to give up the
bishop but alvarez says uh maybe just
rook captures on d7 as this is the
position that uh again mata put in the
thumbnail of the video that's what we
will play so rook captures on d7 and
it's a really an incredible move it wins
the f5 square for the night which could
be crucial uh for for the coming attack
uh but also uh it's uh just uh uh you
know hard hard to play this uh you you
have to play this with surgical
precision with black in order to survive
this uh and is fabio up to it let's uh
let's uh find out so queen captures on
d7 and now bishop to h3 first grabbing
hold of this diagonal attacking the
queen and the rook
and now fabi says all right pawn to f5
which is weird because the bishop can
just capture it
but that's just how good fabi is and now
you have to play bishop captures on f5
and go into this position for example
bishop captures an f5 attacks the queen
and the rook we're going to move the
queen off for a queen trade so now you
don't have time to grab the rook or if
you trade queens we capture with this
rook so we're going to have to move the
queen we're going to play rook to d8 and
alireza doesn't win back his exchange
but he will get
some of the nicer squares here for his
knight and he's going to have constant
pressure against the black king so
that's the way you want to play it
however uh in the game e captures on f5
was played which seems a little bit
better you can always push f6 uh you
know nah
it just seems like it allows so much
more uh but fabi just plays rook c the
e8 and now how can already continue this
uh the problem is you don't have
something like f6 if you could play f6
and not trade anything you'd be you'd be
fine here the problem is after queen to
f7 offering a queen trade there's no
good way to play this if you move the
queen then you've just given up this
pawn and you don't have the attack if
you trade queens captures captures you
can't even miss a black spawn structure
as fabi just captures the knight here so
it's really really terrible for uh for
alireza so he goes knight to h4 that was
the idea he wants to control these
squares here but now just e4 by fabi uh
we have rook to d1 attacking the queen
bringing the rook into the game queen to
f7 offering a queen trade and now uh if
it is a trades then he doesn't have the
attack he's just down material uh but if
he doesn't trade then fabi will just
grab another pawn fabie is not afraid to
grab more material even in
crazy positions like these so queen to
e2 and uh just a nice cold-blooded pawn
grab queen captures an a2 now can
already make something of this time that
fabi wasted grabbing this pawn uh well
let's see knight to g6 he attacks the
rook fabi defends it rook to f7 and now
uh knight back to f4 freeing up this
diagonal for the bishop and so either
knight to f4 or maybe bishop g4 to h5
first and then uh
still you know deciding whether or not
to move the knight so maybe this is
stronger you know just keeping the uh
the knight jump as a as a threat better
than executing it right away uh but okay
uh knight to f4 we have queen to b3 uh
very important move now preparing e3 and
now bishop to g4 alireza wants to get
his bishop over to h5 and now fabi has
to push e3 that's the only way to stop
uh
alireza for from pushing so hard now the
problem is if you play bishop to h5 now
it doesn't really work he captures an f2
with check now the rook is attacking
your queen so you have to capture like
this and now rook captures on f5 is
incredibly strong that's the problem
because now if you play bishop captures
here not just queen captures on d1
nothing is defending the rook and that's
it you can you can resign this and if
you don't capture the rook uh
then you really don't don't have a move
here so that's the problem so instead we
have queen king to g2 if you try
something like
rook to d3 attacking the queen still
just he captures an f2 with check and
you you have to
uh capture with the queen queen captures
you're gonna move the the queen and
everything is perfectly fine uh fabio
will have no no problem playing this
game and winning this game so instead
king the g2 now the pawn cannot capture
as the rook would hang with check
but now we just play rook to d8 fabinho
offers a rook trade we have rook
captures knight captures and now f
captures on e3 alireza grabs that pawn
the only problem is the position is
completely winning for fabi but only if
you play the absolute precise idea so
feel free to pause the video and win the
game for fabi while i give you a couple
of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on uh realizing that
the king and the queen are occupying the
same second rank and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
rook to c7 now rook the c2 is a terrible
threat uh for white to face and there is
no good way to face it uh alireza has to
move the king king to h3 was played now
comes knight to f7 preparing knight to
g5 check which will force the king
further back a further up the board so
bishop to f3 giving the king the g4
square as well but now rook c2 attacking
the queen queen d1 now luckily the
bishop is defending the queen otherwise
we would just play rook captures on h2
and pick up the white queen so that's
very important but now knight g5 would
check king to g4 and it seems like
alireza is safe here and there is
nothing fabi can do but uh fabi plays
the simplest idea that uh leaves
a basically without a move
and that is knight captures on f3 and
now uh what do you play if if you play
queen captures just rook captures on h2
and what are you what are you doing with
this position here white has uh uh white
has no future here uh or if you play uh
what else i played queen to d8 with
czech king the h7 and king captures on
f3 it's a little bit better but not
enough to stop fabi just queen captures
on b2 and again how are you playing this
uh you can't give a check if your queen
was on e8 for example then queen g6
would allow you at least a perpetual so
this is what alireza has to try now
queen to e8 but now just queen back to
f6 not allowing this perpetual we have
e4
trying to push some pawns as this is a
pass pawn but not just rook captures on
h2 fabi shows just how hopeless
alireza's position is there really is no
move you can play here so queen to d7
here we have queen to c3 with check and
with this move both players have played
for the move so the time control has
been reached and none of the players
have to worry about time anymore uh but
time is the least of alleres
concerns so here queen g4 queen to d2
offering a queen trade and of course
queen to a for all it is it declines
this but now pawn to h5 would check
and now there really isn't all that much
you can do here uh or rather even h5
wasn't even played uh
apologies for that uh let us just play
the queen to a4 and resign in this
position because he realized that h5 is
coming and the there is no stopping that
so after playing queen to a4 it was in
this position on move 42 that alireza
furuja resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here so here of
course uh after h5 you resign uh because
whatever you play it gets you checkmated
if king to g5 uh we just play queen d8
check your only move is f6 and queen
captures on f6 will be checkmate if you
go down the board that's not much better
just queen to f2 is checkmate and of
course if you capture the pawn with the
knight which is the only other
way to play queen to e2 check now we
nicely connect with the knight on h5 and
that's it king of four queen captures or
rook captures on h5 uh leaving white
without any counter play now of course
black is up a whole rook uh this is
unplayable
so tough break for alireza who loses his
second game uh in the in the feeder
candidates tournament now he's uh he has
four draws and two losses uh both of the
losses against the leaders of the
candidates uh to fabiana quran and
janine pognishi and it just shows you
that uh
how strong of a player fabi is even with
this incredibly rare move that alireza
prepared this queen to d3 idea that was
uh well uh dare i say it honed to
perfection by none other than boris
girlfriend uh it was still not enough to
take down fabi even with this incredible
rook captures on d7 which really uh
allowed all it is uh to to go for the
attack to grab some critical light
squares here around the black king uh
fabi played at the perfection and uh
well it just wasn't possible to force
anything here
uh so yeah uh that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it tough break for already
but we are still in the first half of
the candidates tournament you know if he
gets a few wins uh uh in the next few
games uh you know he he's definitely
back back in the race but that's uh
easier said than done we'll see how it
goes
uh so yeah once again hope you guys
enjoyed it i would like to thank i would
like to wish a very happy birthday to
anwar the 95 percent american flag numa
and i would like to thank kaushik
varanasi max begin johan bridger and the
voice of reason consulting llc for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
candidates until it finishes so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day